nella gt ragazzi è pervenuto questo
nuovo video sono stati 10 saltati su un
episodio normale dietista ragazzi non
esce un episodio normale di è da circa
secondo me due mesi siamo al 205 credo
non lo so comunque se quando 105
episodio circa volevo rifarmi bisol
normale perché è praticamente sono tutti
space tutti strani uno normale di tanto
è diventato questo lo speciale siamo
come finora ghazi che elevator crash che
gli amori di sopravvivere non
sopravviviamo ma neanche per sbaglio
perfetto tutto a posto
ciao ragazzi si comincia alla grande
allora ragazzi da tempo sono più
abituato giocato male però va bene
sopravviviamo ci sarà un modo solo un
pochettino sopravvissuto in realtà se
vedete mi muovo ancora solo un po
difficile proprio l'ultima volta ragazzi
ma non credo si chiama sanitari
sopravvivere a parte gli scherzi eh
vabbè comunque mi fa piacere che sia
comunque tutto così ancora intelligente
e funzionale cioè penn sono contento 99
per cento imposti voi ragazzi let's go è
la partenza è la è da un po che non
faccio fare colpo di testa la cristiano
ronaldo pazzesco e da un posto che non
faccio gli importi così posso essere
sincero quindi ci può anche stare
le ong rabat e queste bombe oddio veloci
a vincere questo negativo si esplori
prima ci sono troppi ostacoli però non
abbastanza per fermare il buon fa dj che
gioca è pista quando è nata attenzione
beh se non fossi morto all'inizio me
l'avrebbe data questa perché proprio lui
non ho neanche capito come un fatto
maniera opportuna iaccarino questo è
perché mettiamo la sia già all'inizio il
santa 11 con iniziale direi che questo
livello può essere considerato uno dei
migliori in assoluto
let's golf
[Musica]
sono contento di fare lo youtuber verso
zombies ok hanno fatto un libro perfetto
una cosa non devo fare ho fatto quella
credo che io debba saltare tutto ai
ragazzi ho giocato solo una volta blanc
verso zombies non l'ho mai registrato
come mai non mi ha mai non mi ha preso
mai così tanto so che però è uno dei
giochi più giocati al mondo se questo la
smette di guardarmi così che mi mette in
soggezione grazie
ok aspetta perfetto madonna che spinge
in avanti e prego che ha visto qualcosa
di sei a posto tutto per tutto ok è
svenuto sto tizio ma tutto ok come se
niente fosse
sto scrivendo quasi clicca il cervello
grazie ad esso sono adesso smetto di
fare happiness quindi allora penso è
stato molto più difficile del previsto a
quanto pare però xing tour cois è un
blog su in turchese
nel senso che adesso lerock color
turchese va bene io non so neanche cosa
caschi o voglia dire turchese
figuriamoci se fai se metti un certo
colore nelle rop dio
sono vivo non ho più le braccia ti prego
fammi vincere perché non posso fare la
farma niente non vi posso più aggrappare
zio
quindi o mi fai vincere to potrebbero
rompersi le tue le tue braccia ad essi
si sono rotte già da un po però ok tutto
a posto
adesso si sono rotte non è vero ma vanno
sempre indossare un elemento
[Musica]
ma io questo unico sempre in realtà
quindi va beh mi scusi l'arancio b anzi
non mi aggrappo a lei perché ho bisogno
di un riparo
ok va bene lei si può aggrappare ammesso
e vuole uno dei due di bari e dall'altro
un amore che vola però in questo momento
vinto mi ci facciamo neanche troppe
domande
singh quattro facevano un altro non vedo
l'ora che esca il più visti due per
vedere che cacchio succede a livello
proprio di di gente che ci gioca
potrebbe essere la rivelazione dell'anno
è se fanno uscire più due per adesso mi
sono buttato su folk ai ragazzi che
comunque è sempre un ep vis plus
no non è vero mai nella vita scherzavo
c'era un altro ragazzi nato né per cento
il prossimo il meno male
tale arrivederci salve tutto a posto
amici miei come non detto
ma non facciamoci domande signori
cavalca gli arpioni non so se mi devo
preoccupare o cosa però ho notato
ultimamente che vive lì dietro io sono
molto fatti meglio scherzavano a me sono
fatti molto meglio di quelli di una
volta forse ma che adesso sono rimasti
solo i creatori quelli seri e non i
bambinelli vabbè è difficile arrivare al
finale così non so se ve ne siete
accorti prima che proprio non ci arriva
hayward
io ormai smetto di fare commenti perché
sto gioco non ne ha bisogno perciò un po
di imporsi con ragazzi che sono quelli
che mi hanno visto di station alla fine
devo fare non c'è il muro non ho capito
dove c'è un muro invisibile avranno solo
altezza come faccio sempre devo andare
non fa niente per rustock parkour
oh mio dio oh mio dio da un palazzo
all'altro incornata a posto ragazzi ci
sono non faccia caso a me che sto
facendo per costruire i palazzi non fa
niente salve questo questo fatto
benissimo
no ragazzi sono morto ma non fa niente è
fatto benissimo sto livello a parte gli
scherzi
questo è uno dei livelli che sarebbe
finito nella pop dei livelli top di
happy meals se le mie gambe e non pedala
0 da sole secondo me è fatto veramente
bene il suo livello leghe sono hanno
tarato la distanza giusta tra un palazzo
al da un palazzo all'altro mio dio
tutto ok tutto ok ragazzi tutto ok tutto
a posto
e tu che mi credo che io debba superare
stappare come se niente fosse non ho le
braccia che non ci servono
dove vanno a così fratelli ho preso il
muro ho preso un sacco di muri prossimo
il 78 spetta port cose noi e devo farmi
spingere la palla regala sempre sta
storia quadro dove riuscito ad appurare
è così devo farmi spingere la palla di
sotto non so come però la pesca a
saltare sulle mine
forse ci arrivo attenzione mano ero
veramente in dirittura d'arrivo
non ho capito giuseppe ma non ho visto
ma non è vero sono tante volte che vinco
non me lo dà alle volte non vinco e melo
da questo gioco è molto strano
il mid jet piccolo nano ha fatto suo
livello io solo per il nome lo faccio
perché da uno che si chiama piccolo nano
di affetti sole livelli di qualità
perfetto ok meraviglioso ciao e le
ultime tre visto nella mia sanità
mentale stando a mano a deteriorarsi
spider man
les voi questo è un rock swing
travestito dal nome di spider man ma fa
niente
ho fatto un altro mazzia pazzesca ho
saltato una rock come se niente fosse
sono stato il miglior spider man di
questo secolo se posso dirlo allora non
è tale per centi fossimo le scotte fanno
youth performance arrivato perché
mancava niente ci arrivavano per quello
del problema
non fate domande siamo l'ultimo ragazzi
facciamo una roba un po di zucchero
difficile messo al minimi a ok non è
difficile lo so dà una martellata la
gente molto bene questo livello in
qualche modo mi sfoga per il tutto resto
della giornata è stato meraviglioso
giocherai più il con voi oggi ragazzo
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come la
selezione più mi piace anche vari social
comando per fischiare se non stanno così
rischiate e lo scegliamo come sempre
hanno proseguito mi sono fatto malissimo
dalla ragazza
[Musica]